PROFESSOR: So,
WKB approximation,
or semiclassical approximation.
So this is work due
to three people--
Wentzel, Kramers,
and Brillouin--
in that incredible year,
1926, where so much of quantum
mechanics was figured out.
As it turns with many
of these discoveries,
once the discoveries were
made, people figured out
that somebody did them before.
And that person was a
mathematician, Jeffreys,
who did it three years
earlier, in 1923.
The work had not
become very popular.
So some people write JWKB.
But we will not do that.
We'll note Jeffreys, but
we'll follow this more
standard notation.
So these people were dealing
with differential equations
with slowly-varying
spatial coefficients.
That was the main thing.
So we're continuing our
approximation methods.
We've done perturbation theory.
We will add little pieces
to the Hamiltonian.
Now we consider things that
are slowly varying in space.
You might have a very
simple Hamiltonian
where nothing varies in space--
a constant potential.
But as soon as the potential
starts varying slowly,
you have approximation methods.
Those are the methods
we're considering now.
We will also
consider, after we've
finished WKB, time-dependent
perturbation theory, where
still things start
slowly varying in time.
So we'll have many,
many things to do still.
So this is called, also, the
semiclassical approximation.
Because classical physics gives
you intuition about the quantum
wave function.
So it is a lesson in which
you want to learn something
about the quantum wave
function, and you learn it
by using classical physics.
A quantity that is relevant
here is that the Broglie
wavelength of a particle.
This is the Broglie.
And many people say that
semiclassical approximation
has to do with the fact that
the quantum mechanic effects are
not that important.
That may happen.
The Broglie wavelength
is much smaller
than the physically relevant
sizes of your apparatus.
So you have a particle
like an electron.
And if the Broglie
wavelength is very small
compared to the
aperture in the screen,
the letter will go almost
like a classical particle.
When the Broglie wavelength
is comparable with the size
of the aperture
in the screen, you
will get diffraction
effects, and the electrons
will do quantum
mechanical things.
So the semiclassical
approximation
has to do with
lambda being smaller
than the length scale, L,
of your physical problem.
We will refine this.
In fact, the whole
search of understanding
the semiclassical
approximation is
all about understanding
this better.
Because it's a little subtle.
We will end up deciding
that what you need
is that the Broglie wavelength,
suitably generalized,
varies very slowly.
We'll have to generalize
the concept of the Broglie
wavelength.
We might get to it today.
Mathematically, you
can say, OK, I want
this to be sufficiently small.
So semiclassical limit was
just take h going to 0.
You should complain, of course.
h is a constant of nature.
I cannot take it equal to 0.
But on the other hand, they
could imagine other universes,
maybe, where h has different
smaller and smaller values
in which quantum mechanical
effects don't set in
until much smaller scales.
But at the end of
the day, I will
try to consider h to be
small as an idea underlying
a semiclassical approximation.
And the intuition is
that for h small--
we cannot tune it,
but we can say it--
h small lambda becomes small.
The lambda, the Broglie, dB.
You're taking a
quantity with units--
h bar is units.
And saying it's small.
It goes against lots of things.
Things with units are
not supposed to be small.
You should compare it with
the situation we had before.
We had a very nice
and clean situation
with perturbation theory,
where we had a unit-free thing
that we consider it to be small.
This time, we're going to try
to consider h to be small.
And it's going to be more
delicate because it has units.
It's going to be a
more complicated story.
The physics is
interesting, and that's
why this approximation
is harder in some ways
to understand than
the ones we've
done in perturbation theory.
So how does this begin?
It begins by thinking of a
particle in a potential, V
of x.
And the particle
has some energy, E.
And then, if it's classical,
as we're imagining now,
it could be a
three-dimensional potential.
My sketch of course is
just for one-dimensional.
This is E. And you can
solve for p squared, 2m, E
minus V. This is a
notion of local momentum
because it depends on x.
It's the momentum the
particle would have.
When it is at some
position, x, you
will have momentum, p, of x.
And now, nobody forbids
you from declaring
that you're going to define
a position-dependent Broglie
wavelength, which is
going to be h over p
of x is your definition, which
is equal to 2 pi h bar over p
of x.
And it's going to be
local the Broglie.
You see that the Broglie
wavelength, when you first
started in 804, was considered
for a free particle--
always the [INAUDIBLE].
You have a free particle
with some momentum it
has at the Broglie wavelength.
Why was the Broglie
wavelength important?
Because when you write
the wave function,
it's a wave with wavelength
equal to the Broglie
wavelength.
The wave function with
the Broglie wavelength
solves the Schrodinger equation.
That's sort of how
it all came about.
But it was all defined
for a free particle.
The Broglie defined
it for a free particle
with some momentum, p.
And it all made sense, because
you could write a wave function
using the Broglie momentum.
It was in fact E to
the ipx over h bar.
That was your wave function.
But here, you have a particle
moving with varying momenta.
And we don't know how to write
the solution of the Schrodinger
equation, but there's
classically this concept,
and we could define the
local, the Broglie wavelength,
and we will have to
discover what it means
or how it shows up.
But it probably
shows up in some way.
So there's two cases that
probably we should consider.
But before that, we looked
at the Schrodinger equation--
the time-independent
Schrodinger equation.
So it's minus h squared
over 2m Laplacian
of psi of x is equal to
E minus v of x, psi of x.
All these vectors-- that's
why I'm Laplacian, not
second derivatives.
But the right-hand side--
well, if I put the
2m to the other side,
I get minus h squared
Laplacian of psi of x,
is equal to 2m E minus vx.
That's p squared of x, psi of x.
That's the local
momentum squared.
Maybe it's a curiosity, but
it's now nice that the left-hand
side is the momentum
operator squared--
so it's p hat squared
on the wave function--
is equal to p squared of
x times a wave function.
Kind of a nice result.
Nice-looking Schrodinger
equation.
I don't know if you've
seen it like that before.
It's an operator on the left.
And on the right, almost
like an eigenvalue.
It's an illegal eigenvalue.
If it were a real
eigenvalue problem,
there should be a number,
not a function here.
But it's a function that acts
a little like an eigenvalue.
It's a nice way of thinking
of the Schrodinger equation
in the semiclassical
approximation.
Well, no.
No approximation here so far
in the semiclassical language,
in which you call this
the local momentum.
And thus defined, it certainly
is an exact statement--
no approximation whatsoever.
OK, now I want to know these
two circumstances of course.
If you have E greater than v,
you're in an allowed region.
And p squared is really
2m E minus v of x.
And it's convenient to
define h squared k squared
of x, the wave number.
You remember that p equal
hk was good notation.
We use the wave
number sometimes.
We'll have here a local
wave number as well.
And if you're in the
forbidden region,
which energy is less than v--
forbidden region--
then minus p squared
is positive, is 2m v
minus E. That is positive
this time, because
v is greater than E.
And that, we always used
to call the penetration
constant, the kappa,
for wave functions
that decay exponentially.
So we call this h squared
kappa squared of x.
A local decaying
factor wave number.
It can be thought as an
imaginary wave number.
But that's notation.
So, so far, so good.
We will need one more
piece of intuition
as we work with this
semiclassical approximation.
We have not done any
approximation yet.
The approximation
will come soon,
as we will begin solving
the Schrodinger equation
under those circumstances.
And we will take h bar as
an expansion parameter--
will be fine and correct,
but a little subtle.
So the thing that will
help us many times
to understand these things
is to write the wave function
as a complex number.
So suppose you have
a wave function.
We will write it as a complex
number in the polar form--
radius times face.
So the radius is
going to be rho of x.
The probability density,
I claim, is this.
And there is a phase that
I will write as E to the i
over h bar, S of x and t.
It looks a little
like an action.
And it's, to some degree,
the beginning of the path
into rule formulation.
It has lots of connections
with the action principle.
So here, rho and s
are going to be real.
So this is truly
scale factor in front
that determines the value.
This is a pure phase, because
it's an imaginary number
times a real thing.
S has units of h bar,
or angular momentum.
And indeed, psi squared is
equal to rho of x and t.
If you loop psi squared.
The reason we focus
on this wave function
is that our solutions
of WKB are going
to have exactly that form.
So we need to have an
intuition as to what
the observables of
this wave function are.
So the other observable
is the current density.
If you remember, it's h bar over
m, imaginary part of psi star
gradient psi.
So this must be calculated.
So what is this?
Gradient of psi-- we must
take the gradient of this.
Gradient's a derivative, so it
acts on one, acts on the other.
When it acts on
the first, it first
acts as the relative 1 over
2 squared of rho of x and t,
times the gradient of rho,
times the phase factor, plus now
I have to take the
gradient on this quantity,
and this will bring down an i,
an h bar, the gradient of S,
and then multiplied by
the whole wave function,
because this factor remains
and the exponential remains.
Now we can multiply by
psi star to form what
we need to get for the current.
So psi star [INAUDIBLE] psi.
If I multiply by that, I'm
multiplying by the top line.
For the first factor, I
get 1/2 gradient of rho.
The exponentials cancel.
And for the second
part, we get plus i
over h bar, gradient of S,
times psi squared, which is rho.
The imaginary part
of this is equal 1
over h bar, rho gradient of s.
So finally, the
current, which is
h bar over m, times
that imaginary part,
is rho gradient of s, over m.
A very nice formula.
Basically, it says that the
phase factor in the wave
function determines the
probability current.
And it also says that if
you want to think of this,
here are the surfaces
of constant phase.
Here is our space.
And S constant.
So here is one
valley of the phase,
another valley of the phase.
Those are surfaces in
space of constant phase.
The current is
orthogonal to that.
So the current is
proportional to the gradient.
The gradient of a function
is always proportional.
It's a normal vector to the
surfaces of constant values.
So the current is orthogonal to
the surfaces of constant phase.
If you have a fluid
mechanics interpretation,
J is rho v in fluids.
So, so far, everything I've said
could have been said in 804.
These are properties of
a general wave function.
This is how you
compute the current.
The useful thing is
that our WKB wave
functions are going to be
presented in that language.
So if you think of the
analogy with fluid mechanics.
The current is the charge
density times the velocity,
and therefore the velocity
would be identified
with gradient of S over m.
Or the momentum would be
identified with gradient of S.
That's not a quantum mechanical
rigorous identification.
Because gradient
of S is a function.
And therefore, p there
would be a function.
And a function of momentum--
momentum in quantum
mechanics is an operator,
and it has eigenvalues,
which are numbers.
They're not functions.
But we already have
seen the beginning
of some momentum function.
So that analogy is
actually quite nice.
Let me give you an example,
and conclude with that.
If you have a free particle,
you have a wave function psi
of x and t, which is E,
to the ipx over h bar,
times minus iEt over h bar.
So in this case, rho
is equal to 1, an S--
remember, S is read by having
an i over an h bar out.
And that gives you
p dot x minus Et.
So for a free particle,
the gradient of S
is indeed just the momentum.
You take this gradient,
and it's that.
And therefore, that's a
rigorous interpretation
when you have a free particle,
that the gradient of S
is going to be the momentum.
Interestingly, the derivative
of S with respect to time
is minus the energy.
What will happen in the
semiclassical approximation
is that this S over
there will depend on x,
and this p will depend
on x, and it will be
this p that depends on x here.
And we will see how
to solve this equation
in an approximation scheme where
the changes are a little slow.
And the notation S
here is also motivated
because actions in
classical mechanics
actually have this property.
The gradient of
the action-- if you
think of the action as a
function of coordinates,
which is something you don't
usually do, but if you do,
in somewhat advanced
classical mechanics,
you see that the derivatives
of the action-- spatial
derivatives are the momentum,
and the time derivatives
are the energy.
It's a nice relation
between classical mechanics,
and justifies once more the name
of semiclassical approximation,
which we will continue
to develop next time.
See you then.